bonsoir bonsoir excuses nous te déranger
à cette heure là on est tout seul chez
toi ok d'accord alors nous on a deux
voyageurs on est parti dans un voyage un
peu particulier puisque on est parti
sans argent sans vêtement en direction
de la norvège
et ce soir on cherche et hébergement
chez l'habitant cette direction là j'ai
essayé d'appeler les perdants si vous
voulez y reviennent ce soir
ouais mais l'auteur parce qu'il suscite
chez des amis d'accord c'est mal mais à
trop bien oui bonjour la maman de césar
bonjour la maman de césar
la première fois qu'on fait une demande
d'hébergement chez l'habitant par
téléphone téléphone
eh ben ça veut dire que vous lui fait
vraiment confiance que abba volontiers
avec grand plaisir de césar sa commande
par semaine ok d'accord très bien
apprendre à qui fait que tous les gestes
sans vouloir s'est rendu compte que plus
on s'alléger dans le sac à dos plomb
s'alléger dans notre confort et plus on
devait faire confiance en la route et
plus le voyage se charger de surprises
inattendues de découverte
et puis on sait bien un jour non mais il
faut vraiment qu'on aille vers du
dépouillement
jusqu'au jour on s'est dit allez chiche
on y va quoi et ça a été assez
merveilleux de découvrir des trésors
derrière ça parce que derrière la
parente difficultés de voyager avec très
peu de moyens parce que quand on a
commencé étudiants on n'avait pas de
moyens et le choix de d'avoir un impact
environnemental le plus bas possible
en fait on a découvert que les 13 heures
ils nous attendent au coin de la rue
quand on rencontre les gens quand entre
nous il faut se faire confiance
il faut accepter d'être petit pendant
que l'autre est plus fort et puis mène
le duo puisions univers va trouver une
solution et ça aujourd'hui ça n'a pas de
prix
[Musique]
des plus grands auteurs pour quelqu'un
qui voudrait voyager sans argent ça
souvent l'idée que mais je vais être
pris pour un parasite les gens vont dire
ben t'as qu'à travailler si jamais tu
veux voyager comme ça et donc un conseil
qu'on pourrait donner par rapport à
cette heure c'est de toujours voyagé
avec une boîte à cadeaux avec quelque
chose à offrir est rentré du bois faire
un coup de ménage à les vider le vert
peu importe ça c'est des cd des aides
qui sont très précieuses quand on est
pris dans un quotidien qu'on a que des
voyageurs qui certes d'un point de vue
poète une charge supplémentaire mais
peuvent apporter beaucoup de beauté et
beaucoup de soutien si vous avez un don
ce soit dans la chanson dans le théâtre
dans le conte dans la poésie dans le
slam quoi que ce soit qui peut être
offert ça c'est hyper apprécié moi je me
souviens par exemple quand je suis parti
aux etats-unis la première fois j'avais
appris des recettes de cuisine de chez
moi très simple genre les crêpes et le
gratin dauphinois et en fait partout où
j'étais peu importe la culture du coin
j'arrivais toujours à trouver les
ingrédients pour faire la petite recette
de chez moi c'était une manière de
partager un peu de jeunes et puis de
rendre service l'objectif on est content
de vous rencontrer prochainement ce
mois-ci mouthe et notre manière de
voyager c'est le soir c'est de dormir
chez l'habitant demander l'hospitalité
et on a on adorerait pouvoir vous rendre
un service on échange puisque notre
façon de voyager on n'amène pas de
l'argent mais on a quatre bras quatre
jambes qui peut faire des choses
quand on voyage comme ça sans argent
très souvent il va y avoir des
opportunités qui vont s'ouvrir à vous et
nous on vous invite vraiment à dire oui
le plus souvent possible cette année a
osé sortir de votre zone de confort et
rencontrer des gens vous n'avez pas
l'habitude de rencontrer des situations
vous n'avez pas l'habitude de vivre et
quelque part vous ouvrira de nouveau
possible je me souviens dans un voyage
en chercher à manger parce qu'on avait
très faim et on allait voir le gymnase
qui était sur notre route est en fait
dans ce gymnase il y avait une fête pour
les personnes âgées du village
on s'est retrouvé avec 80 personnes
âgées à danser et faire et dont j'ai
appelé la galette des rois
c'était complètement improbable s était
super moment d'ailleurs on a rencontré
une des grands-mères qui nous invite qui
nous a invités ensuite à dormir chez eux
aussi faire confiance à cette petite
voix en nous qui dit là attention je le
sens pas quoi parce que parfois sous
prétexte de l' aventure du nouveau de
l'alliance en chou on y va un peu aussi
se mettre en danger
ce que le monde c'est pas juste un monde
de bisounours avec des gens
bienveillants il ya aussi des situations
potentiellement dangereuses avec des
gens mais aussi dans la nature avec des
animaux quand y en avait un qui le
sentais pas les deux sa ligne là dessus
parce qu'il s'agit pas de se mettre en
danger et d'ailleurs notre premier
serment entre nous quand on a commencé
ces voyages c'était règle numéro une on
revient vivant en fait nous dans ce
qu'on a découvert dans mon voyage c'est
que l'aspiration profonde de gens qui
voyagent souvent c'est ça si on veut
laventure n'en veut revenir vivant est
un exemple concret c'est quand on n'est
pas quand on est une femme par exemple
et qu'on veut s'essayer au stop
une règle de base ça peut être je ne
monte pas avec un ou plusieurs hommes je
mens toujours avec une femme ou
éventuellement un couple et une fois
qu'on est suffisamment en confiance là
dedans on peut peut-être un jour se dit
allez tiens là ce grand père seul où ce
jeune homme je me sens en confiance
aller j'y vais mais avant il ya cette
base hyper secure qui est déjà installé
quoi pour une famille par exemple qui
aimeraient dormir chez l'habitant
c'est difficile de voyager avec les
enfants parce qu'on peut faire par
exemple se faire un échange de maison
c'est gratuit ça coûte rien et pourtant
on découvre la culture locale avec les
voisins avec toute la vie le folklore du
pays où on va voyager
[Musique]
et bah oui on a besoin de prendre une
douche n'a besoin de dormir on a besoin
de trouver à manger potentiellement sur
voyage sans argent en fait ses besoins
ses des portes d'entrée merveilleuse
pour aller rencontrer les gens parce que
derrière le besoin il ya quelque chose
qui nous relient c'est que on a besoin
de se reposer on a besoin de se sentir
propre et ça on l'a tous vécu
donc c'est un endroit où même si on
partage pas la même langue on peut se
comprendre par exemple dans notre voyage
à rodrigues de cette dernière saison on
avait envie de faire de la moto ce top
puisque lille était trop grande pour la
faire à pied est trop sauvage pour la
faire en auto stop est en fait par le
biais de notre besoin de mobilité et de
trouver une moto on a rencontré son
propriétaire l'a rencontré une personne
qui nous a aidés à la réparer quand elle
est tombée en panne et une autre qui
nous a mis l'essence dans merci de nous
aider à prendre notre envol
c'était un prétexte en fait à la
rencontre c'est implique un deuxième
élément c'est la clarté dans l'intention
bonjour je viens vous rencontrer et je
suis clair sur be mots parce que je
cherche un hébergement je vais pas
tourner autour du pot pendant un quart
d'heure et puis faire semblant que non
je cherchais un hébergement ce que ce
serait joyeux pour vous de m'aider ou
nous aider dans cette démarche
si la personne n'est pas disponible ou
n'accepte pas nos demandes
ok aucun problème on aura passé quelques
secondes à se connecter et puis on trace
un taux donc ça implique une autre
attitude qui essaie de prendre notre
responsabilité c'est nous qui avons
choisi de partir en voyage c'est nous
qui avons choisi de partir en voyage
sans argent ce qui implique de trouver
l'hébergement
donc si à un moment donné on nous dit
non c'est pas la faute de l'autre c'est
à nous de prendre la responsabilité de
bah ouais mec tu as choisi ça a juste
bien assumé va voir un peu plus loin
trouve d'autres solutions quel que soit
votre objectif ou le rêve que vous
suivez mettez toujours en priorité la
qualité de la connexion avec les gens
que vous allez rencontrer et votre
environnement
on s'est aperçu que on pouvait dès fois
s'obstiner sur un objectif faire
l'ascension d'une montagne rencontré une
personne il use quoi que ce soit et que
c'est un moment donné on perdait cette
sensibilité soit dans le binôme de
voyages soit avec les gens qu'on
rencontre on passe à côté du voyage
parce qu'on peut arriver sur la ligne
d'arrivée mais sentir bien seul bonjour
bonne anniversaire
merci on a été contacté il ya trois
jours auparavant de mariée comme cadeau
d'anniversaire vagabondage en fait il ay
l' office d' expérience initiatique
parce que comme tout est nouveau puisque
par définition on peut rien prévoir
c'est une initiation au froid c'est mimi
une initiation à l'autre c'est une
initiation aux désaccords dans le binôme
c'est une initiation à la fin et dans
les stations
détachement matériel sinisation
inattendue et quelque part c'est pour ça
que ça nous plaît tant est que ça fait
bientôt dix ans qu'on voyage comme ça
c'est que c'est une école pour ses
voyages et ses des enseignements
convient après dans nos relations
personnelles professionnelles
enfin qu'on essaye d'intégrer au mieux
après dans le resto dit